when people are always making fun of
people I know you always say like turn
your back out like it didn't happen is
there a point where you say like you got
to stand up for yourself and like you
know have that self-confidence I think
the self-confidence is the reverse being
able to walk away and not giving a [__]
is actual self-confidence confronting
someone saying you're a [__] face I
don't think that's self-confidence I
think that's your own pain reflecting by
the way everybody's gonna have a Tipping
Point yeah but the strength of the
self-confidence comes from not giving a
[__] makes sense yeah that's that next
level yeah punching them in the face is
like in between